for hundreds of years
Muslims used to go out into empty fields
looking at the sky to figure out what
Ramadan begins these days though clerics
here in Pakistan and elsewhere use
telescopes to get first sight of the new
moon once spotted Ramadan starts it's
the holiest month in the Islamic
calendar when Muslims stop eating and
drinking from sunrise to sunset the
fasting allows worshipers to devote
themselves to their faith and remember
the sufferings of the poor but during
the unprecedented coronavirus emergency
Muslims are abandoning many of Ramadan's
traditions and rituals they won't be
able to invite their loved ones the
neighbors or the poor to join the
evening fast breaking meal known as
iftar as ghovat 19 spreads restrictions
are being enforced governments have
closed borders impose curfews lock downs
and encourage social distancing to
contain the contagion Islam's holiest
site in Mecca is usually teeming with
worshipers from all over the world
during Ramadan it's closed this year as
part of the Santa government's campaign
to curb the virus spread getting people
everywhere to observe social distancing
in Ramadan won't be easy
the highlight of Ramadan is the night of
destiny where Muslims believe the holy
book the Quran was first revealed to the
Prophet Muhammad and where the gates of
heaven are open Muslims
spent the night in contemplation and
prayers Emo's a ritual they are being
asked to perform at home this time
Islam's most sacred month man to
encourage unity praying together and
breaking their fast together may end up
being a month of relative solitude
Hashima para al jazeera